at least two people are dead as
wildfires here in the u.s. rage in
California the outbreak comes despite
extraordinary measures by power
companies to minimize the risk their
national correspondent William la
jeunesse is live tonight in Porter Ranch
neighborhood of Los Angeles good evening
William well Bret the fire began around
nine o'clock last night when the Santa
Ana winds literally jumped over that
Ridge raced into the LA basin devastated
this community while many slept I could
see the flames coming over that Ridge I
said we gotta go everything's on fire up
there everything the house is
everything's on fire
it's bad a fire exploding overnight
north of Los Angeles as Santa Ana winds
ripped through the San Fernando Valley
gusting to more than 50 miles an hour
pretty shortly before sunrise at Porter
Ranch this fire is 0% contained and
burning out of control
no one really knows what these winds so
we're just hoping one of us a hundred
thousand evacuated here and two
fatalities one a man in his 50s suffered
a heart attack trying to protect his
home another died in this fire east of
Los Angeles that destroyed a mobile home
park this events gonna take a few days
with strong sustained winds and humidity
under 10% firefighters are on defense
protecting homes and dropping retardant
hoping to slow a fire chewing some 800
acres an hour
it's a rough estimate right now but
we're looking at a number of at least 25
homes have been damaged several hundred
thousand Californians mostly in the
northern part of the state remain
without electricity as power companies
have voluntarily pulled the plug fearing
liability with downed power lines
we're seeing a scale and scope of
something that no state and the 21st
century should experience what's
happened is unacceptable in addition to
criticism from governor Newsom the
family of a 67 year old man in Northern
California is blaming utility when his
oxygen machine stopped twelve minutes
after the utilities shut off power to
prevent more wildfires as for this one
Bret about 13% contained and they hope
to have it under control by the end of
the weekend
it's also William thank you